thank you billions of dollars have been
gained and lost
during just the last few days and as a
political issue as you just heard there
it made for some interesting bed fellows
with aoc on the same side as
ted cruz and rush limbaugh charles payne
of fox business joins us now to kind of
straighten this all out good evening
charles i heard you
earlier yesterday uh talking about this
and
getting fired up about it a lot of
people have come down and said
you know should this be changed the way
the markets work
talk to me about it well here's the
thing
brett i've been doing this for over 30
years i've taken companies public as a
broker
i took my own company public and i've
been a consultant i know this industry
inside and out
and this has been one area that has
upset me tremendously for a long time
now market purists and you know these
rich headphones
folks always say hey shorting is good it
helps liquidity it keeps the market
running it's a pretty good thing
what's not a good thing is if you issued
bret
if you issued ten shares and and brett
bear incorporated
and somebody saw that it was worth a
hundred dollars and thought maybe i can
drive this to a buck
it's a great company so and somehow they
were able to borrow
20 shares now you only issue 10 but
somehow they can borrow 20
and sell it and keep selling it and
pound it
and pound it and pound it and pound it
into submission
and along the way all the investors who
believed in brett bear incorporated
also lose their shirt and this is what's
happening this is not about trading
this is about a cottage industry of very
wealthy billionaires
who have been able to pound stocks into
complete submission it's not about a
trade
it's not about them thinking something
is oversold it's about them thinking
that a stock
is hopeless that there's no brokerage
firms covering it or the most brokerage
firms have a hold
rating on it maybe a sale rating no
one's going to come to its defense
they're not looking for a trade they're
looking for total submission
so all of a sudden you get a bunch of
young investors mostly novice investors
excited
and they start to notice hey if you buy
these stocks up
sometimes they get squeezed so the
person that's shorted your stock at 10
may have to buy it at 12 may have to buy
it at 14. they start getting a little
nervous
and on and on and on this is what we
call a classic short squeeze it's the
ultimate short squeeze
now what compounds the error the problem
in addition to these hedge funds already
being able to borrow unlimited amounts
of stock
and artificially sell it right this is
not a real market they are making a
market to the downside
now on top of this today you have all of
these platforms including robinhood and
i say shame on them
who have stopped these same investors
from buying the stock so guess what they
can only sell it
okay they can sell it the shorts can
sell it of course it's going to go down
it's really a serious injustice and if
something's going to be done
something should be done on the ability
to to get a 140 percent of a company's
float uh which obviously doesn't exist
and sell it into the market i think you
start there
right so you know for the people who say
listen we're doing this to protect
the little guy you say what the little
guy
some little guy's made a lot of money in
a short period of time
but there could be some holding the bag
at the end and the big guys
often don't well the big guys get theirs
but here's the thing i i just think it's
a disingenuous argument
uh 20 years ago general elect was
general electric was the number one
stock in the in
an entire world there was a number one
market cap and wall street say hey
say to everybody put this in your
retirement fund all right
50 bucks a share it went to 10. it went
to six it went to six
uh you know so you can lose money on the
blues of blue chip stocks
the bottom line is the stock market's
supposed to be democratized
everyone's supposed to be able to take a
shot and if you and if you get burned
you get burned that's what the stock
market is
it's a free market exchange i think it's
going higher
you think it's going lower let's play by
the same rules so
i don't think that these platforms did
this for the little guy i really believe
they circled the wagons
to help the hedge funds who control wall
street who by the way
buy the order flow from robin hood so
they didn't do this to save the little
guy
you don't you don't seduce people into
trading by giving them free stock
and these commercials and talking about
the beauty of investing
and then when you have the biggest folks
on wall street right there ready to
crack
pull a rug out from under those same
people you seduce into the market it's a
shame it really is
charles i'd love your perspective on it
and this is not the end of this story
thanks man